how's it going everybody
there has been an apparent Avengers for
plot leak that has been going around the
internet I've gotten many requests from
some of you to go over it and give my
thoughts on it so here we are so a few
things one the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues all you have to
do to enter is Hulk smash that subscribe
button like this video and comment below
with your thoughts in the video and your
favorite superhero to always take these
alleged plot leaks with a grain of salt
but 3 this has come from an alleged
source that has been pretty reliable in
the past they were actually right about
the majority of the events of Avengers
infinity war so you never know
regardless I'm going to go over it for
you guys
so this theory talks about a few things
that actually make a lot of sense and
line up with what we know already one of
them of course being time travel another
one is the arrival of Professor Hulk and
him wielding the Infinity Gauntlet this
lines up with a previous plot leaked so
time travel and Professor Hulk wielding
the Infinity Gauntlet already line up
with the previous supposed plot leaks
and then in this theory we're going to
get a completely different look on Tony
Stark and Thanos
ok so let's dive into it again take this
plot leak with a grain of salt but here
it is for your pleasure
ok so according to this plot leaked
Avengers 4 we'll start off with ant-man
traveling back in time to events before
Iron Man 1 he of course gets there
through a time vortex in the quantum
realm that was mentioned in the
post-credits scene of ant-man and the
loss by Janet Van Dyne when he gets to
this part in time he ends up finding
Hank Pym and they end up working on a
sling ring it would make sense that one
of the first people that Scott looks for
is dr. Hank Pym as far as the sling ring
goes perhaps they are trying to do this
so they can figure out a way to access
the quantum realm
now obviously the sling ring is dr.
strangest thing as the master of the
mystic arts and you would definitely
call it magic but in the first Thor
movie Thor explains that where he's from
magic and science are one in the same so
it's not a too far
idea because you're right look
your ancestors called it magic and you
call it science well I come from a place
where they're one in the same thing but
here's where it gets kind of interesting
eternity shows up so eternity is a
cosmic entity and is the actual
embodiment of the multiverse and
eternity can manipulate the multiverse
to do essentially whatever he wants to
do eternity has no physical body but can
warp space and matter into a
manifestation that can be perceived by
humans and all other species so eternity
shows up and for his own selfish reasons
ends up helping them he gives them
special gauntlets that allowed them to
control their movement in time and then
this is apparently where the title
sequence comes into play so music starts
Avengers title comes on let's call it in
game and we go to the next scene so
after the title sequence we cut to Titan
where we see Iron Man and nebula
starting to make their way back to earth
to regroup with the remaining Avengers
this makes sense because obviously after
the snap Tony's going to want to see who
is still alive and what else is nebula
really going to do she wants to undo
Thinnes to snap so it makes sense that
she would go with Tony plus she doesn't
have any family or friends left besides
Rocket but she doesn't know that he's
alive right now so they go and they
regroup with the other Avengers but then
apparently Thor goes to hell he goes to
hell to build an army of fallen Vikings
much like hella did in Thor Ragnarok
speaking of hella she's there as well
along with Heimdall this isn't a too
far-fetched idea because again in Thor
Ragnarok we saw hella do this it would
make sense that Thor could possibly do
this as well now Asgard is destroyed and
so is the eternal flame but again he's
going to hell so perhaps there's a
different way to get this Viking army
he's talking about
so cutting back to all of the other
Avengers regrouped together ant-man pops
out of a time vortex he then proceeds to
tell all of them what is going on and
gives them the sling ring apparently
within the first hour of all of this
happening Thanos finds out about the
sling ring once he finds out he sends
his army the Chitauri and the outriders
against the Avengers and in return
Thor sends his army of fallen Vikings
against Thanos his army
[Music]
so here's where more time-travel comes
into play because apparently in this
battle future Thor and future Captain
America are in it and during the battle
they both end up dying
Thanos then sends his army against the
Avengers in the sling ring I'm not too
sure what that means
but that's what it says so this fall's a
little bit into an old plot leak about
Avengers 4 that says Thor and Captain
America will fight together and Captain
America will end up lifting Thor's
hammer before he dies it doesn't say
that in this plot leaked but again it
did in a past one so I'm just connecting
the dots here so now ant-man is with the
Avengers so they know how to time-travel
now so the Avengers start to travel
across time to collect the stones and
stop danos this falls in line with some
of the other plot leaks that we've heard
so far
The Avengers figuring out time travel
going back in time collecting the
Infinity stones for themselves so they
can forge their own Infinity Gauntlet
undo Thanos to snap and prevent it from
ever happening and this just kind of
makes sense because right now at the end
of Avengers infinity war Thanos has all
of the Infinity stones and it seems like
he's definitely on a distant planet
somewhere so they really have no way of
getting the Infinity stones so really
one of the only options they are left
with is to travel back in time and
collect Infinity stones from the past so
that makes sense to me so they go back
in time to right after where Red Skull
is transported by the tesseract and they
grab Captain America from the past as a
replacement for the future cap who is
now dead so they continue to travel back
through time visiting past events they
go back to the Battle of New York the
events of age of Ultron guardians of the
galaxy and before Thor the dark world it
doesn't say how but it does say Captain
Marvel tags along on their
time-traveling adventures but she
doesn't really do much until the last
hour of the movie so this kind of makes
sense we've all seen the leaked photos
of the Avengers back at the Battle of
New York Captain America wearing his old
uniform and Tony looks like he is
actually from the future and if Captain
Marvel is everything that people
been saying she's going to be Kevin
Feige says that she's going to be the
most powerful superhero in the MCU it
would make sense that they save her for
the end because she's probably too Opie
would probably make the movie a little
too easy for the Avengers so then it
said that they go back further in time
to before Thor and Hawkeye grabs Odin's
gauntlet now it's heavily debated among
fans of whether or not
Odin actually had a real Infinity
Gauntlet mostly due to thor ragnarok
we're hella is in Odin's vault and she
says that the Infinity Gauntlet in there
is fake as she pushes it over thank
whoever many people do agree that the
one that was in there is fake but he
actually had a real one just not stored
inside the vault because it was kept in
a place that was even more secretive and
secured many people actually believe
that Odin collected the Infinity stones
himself hundreds and hundreds of years
ago before scattering them out again
okay so Doctor Strange eventually makes
his way out of the soul stone and goes
back in time in the sling ring I think
many people believe that dr. strange
will be back in Avengers 4 and actually
play a pretty big role in the movie so
this makes sense
so Fanus finds out about the Avengers
attempting to go back in time and
collect their own Infinity stones and
forge their own Infinity Gauntlet and
when he figures this out
he again sends his army to them now
here's where this supposed it plot leak
gets a little crazy apparently in this
battle half of the Avengers from the
past and half of the Avengers from the
future die The Hulk ends up wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet but then gets his arm
cut off he later then gets a mechanical
one so this actually lines up with a
previous plot leak as well where
professor Hulk is coming into play and
of interest for and he wields the
Infinity Gauntlet but he gets his arm
cut off this previous plot leaked is
backed by the fact that the first
official image for Avengers four that
came out shows professor Hulk well it
shows what people believe to be
professor Hulk so this does line up with
that here is where the plot just takes
crazy turn eventually Thanos is killed
and the gauntlet along with the Infinity
stones are destroyed
Thanos dying in Avengers 4 isn't much of
a shock but what happens after is after
Thanos is dead and the stones in the
gauntlet are destroyed Tony absorbs the
power of the Infinity stones and then
eternity reveals himself to be a future
version of Tony who has ascended his
mortal body it turns out that eternity
has been manipulating events throughout
time and the only people who truly had
free will are Doctor Strange Hulk Red
Skull and vanos as it turns out eternity
needed dr. strange to get rid of
Dormammu he reveals to Tony that he will
become a conqueror and rule over the
universe and that the people will
remember him as Kang the Conqueror
that's right
this plot leaked says that Kang the
Conqueror is going to be in Avengers 4
and not only that they're saying that
Kang the Conqueror eternity and Tony
Stark are the same person the last 20
minutes of the movie is a 20 minute
battle of everyone vs. king they can't
beat him so eventually Doctor Strange
goes back in time and kills Tony before
he becomes king slash eternity I'm going
to allow them in the end the Avengers
are happy that there is no longer a war
or any possible threats and the last
thing this plot league says is that in
the post-credit scene it shows Ultron
waking up okay so that is the entire
plot leaked as it has been reported now
I'll give you my opinion on it
where we see and please allow me to
finish this because it's gonna seem like
a bit of a jump we see fan OHS who was
the villain teased at the end of the
first Avengers movie deal Isis okay
Tony's truck realizes I know who that is
I think that there were a lot of things
in this pot league that lined up with
previous plot leaks and theories that
many people have that are true and we
will see in Avengers 4 and here's the
thing about Kang the Conqueror his story
is so
complicated so Kang is actually from the
30th century and from an alternate
timeline this timeline was created from
people going back in time and altering
the events of the past so according to
this plot leek and other plot leaks that
we've heard that definitely happens the
Avengers go back in time changing events
to try and collect the Infinity stones
now Kang the Conqueror his real name is
actually Nathaniel Richards and in the
comics we see Nathaniel and Tony Stark
at the same time so we know they're not
the same person
however the writers and the producers
and directors can do whatever they want
in the MCU so it doesn't mean it can't
happen again Nathaniel is from the 30th
century and he was pretty much a genius
much like Tony is a genius and Nathaniel
comes across a time-travel device much
like Tony will come across time-travel
in Avengers 4 so there are a few
connections here time travel was
actually well discovered in the 30th
century it was just illegal ken came
across a time-travel device and
essentially just broke the law and went
back in time to Egypt and dubbed himself
a pharaoh now King would go on to jump
across different alternate timelines and
eventually in one of those timelines
would conquer the world
thus spawning the villain King the
Conqueror this is something I could see
happening to Tony Stark he discovers
time travel and his genius mind wants to
do all these different things and go
explore different timelines I'm not
saying I believe it will happen but it
could the point being they could connect
it somehow in the MCU although I don't
believe they'll do this it just seems
way too complicated and one thing I
don't believe is that they will go back
in time and kill Tony Stark and leave it
there and be done with it not gonna
happen
and I also can't believe that they would
have Kang the Conqueror / Tony Stark
turn into eternity
obviously the logic of this plot leak is
that Tony discovers time-travel goes on
to become King to conquer absorbs all
the power the Infinity stones turning
him into eternity again it could happen
but it's just too messy and I don't see
it ending that way
so again there are many things in this
plot leak that I do believe are true
that do line up and I think we'll see an
Avengers for however I cannot believe
the ending so that's what I think about
this plot leak many of you asked me to
do a video on it and share my opinion so
there it is I'm sure everyone has just
tons of thoughts and ideas and comments
so please make sure you tell me in the
comments below I know this supposed plot
leak is pretty crazy so I'm looking
forward to hearing what you all have to
say and again
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
continues if you would like to enter all
you have to do is be a subscriber like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf the chair 20 truck realizes that
there has been a disturbance in what he
will call a time ribbon for the time
being I will allow
[Music]
you